you can't be 13 and like 45 exactly yeah
because that's considered statutory I
think also crazy yeah yeah crazy
[Music]
all right Japan has just had a massive
update in its law
no dancing after 9 p.m oh wow who does
that help yeah no there's actually a no
dancing law in in this one area is so
funny where it's just the old ass law
that they didn't update no dancing of
any kind not even after a certain time
like oh damn and then this nightclub got
in trouble it was just so far all right
so this law it's it's being updated for
the first time in a hundred years
does that have to do with vehicle
emissions no it's a long ass try to
decisions I want to spin that to a pun
man I couldn't no because I was thinking
like 100 years got to be like Technology
based or something right you know what's
funny is it's totally not it's just all
down to the human body baby so what is
dancing it's not dancing twin body
you're not allowed to be fat
that's really cool but no it's not
that's really cool
it's pretty great is it a gender thing
it has to do with genders in a way but
not like that not like how you thinking
it it's um
something Between the Lakes sags for
real oh yeah no sex after nine people
isolation on the dick now whoa
I know I know that's that's a sexy thing
we like the mystery
no contraceptives allowed
because they're having a population
problem Oh that you know what that
should have been you gotta leave it in
that should have been it but it's not
bad no I have only bad guesses all right
in between
just pick the number okay so I didn't
even notice but the age of sexual
consent in Japan was 13. no that's too
low and now it's being moved to
not 60.
is it 16 it's 16 yeah I just thought
they're probably going based on the UK
or the Europe one UK UK 16 one of those
either UK or Europe or one of the
countries out there yeah it's like six
that's the average yeah 13 to 16. I
think yeah that's crazy so even last
year was 13 because it just changed this
year that's insane that's really young
it's crazy that for something that like
it was 13 like well it's 100 years ago
they didn't talk about it that much
because 100 years ago women got married
at like
16th and then they started popping out
kids at like 17 18. yeah so
that makes sense yeah this is crazy it
didn't change for 100 years well because
think about it so like for out here
right we um we have to get a uh we have
to go up until High School I think out
there it's it's eighth grade oh okay so
after eighth grade you you have a choice
of whether apprenticeship or
like uh trade school or you continue
your education
yeah I'm kind of mad at Epstein's lawyer
why he should have set up his Island
over there
I I think on you're a green zipped right
now
I think it's still illegal for like um
like uh someone 18 plus to have like I
said that yeah there's got to be a
five-year Gap or something yeah yeah
yeah
you can't be 13 in like 45 exactly yeah
because that's considered statutory I
think also crazy yeah yeah crazy so they
actually have rules about that that's I
feel like they don't have that they have
that here they do they have the same
yeah they have that here it's it's
called statutory
I just can't keep up with all these
[__] States like because in the
Midwest states
like you know how we every time we cover
a story like this we find out like oh
it's in Kentucky and the age of consent
in Kentucky is like 15. well that's the
thing that's strange is that we even
though every state has different consent
ages the media portrays us like it's 18
everywhere because when you watch movies
it's always 18. but that's [__]
because in the U.S you could get married
under 18. so there's like weird laws
here too it's not all straight 18. I
mean R Kelly pulled something sort of
similar right did he marry somebody
Aaliyah Aaliyah yeah yeah oh how was she
I think she's like 16 or something
people don't talk about that enough huh
I feel like that should be part of it
it's old bro
we need to interrupt ourselves more
so there's there's another uh extra
thing that has been banned
and it's exactly what you think is bad
dancing no
what is a problem what's a problematic
thing that happens in Japan on the train
not the groping not the group oh really
wait what is it like upskirt like
pictures oh so that's a thing huh
I've never seen any sights ever about
this no I didn't know
I didn't know that was allowed before
well no it wasn't loud but it just
wasn't it wasn't official specifically
yeah I guess it wasn't in it wasn't in
stone you know but like it's one of
those problems that they've had for a
while and they've tried to fix it in
other ways like they would make it so
remember there's like a thing with your
camera phone there's no camera on this
make a sound that you can't turn off oh
yeah the the shutter yeah like some of
them they it goes woof like a dog oh
yeah someone take a picture
or like people would always put their
like camera phones or whatever on like a
a walking stick that's crazy yeah
whatever happened to just those uh
mirrors on the shoes
dude those were best sellers yeah yeah
all right it gets crazy out there when
you're in the train though like it feels
like you're in a rave or or like you're
just trying to exit a ball game and then
like you know through the hall you're
just like shoulder to shoulder all
[__] crowded like that and so like
there's probably pervs out there that
are like
perfectly timing everything so they can
just go oh yeah yeah especially if it's
a daily occurrence like you got lots of
chances dude because I've always heard
about people on in Japan on this on the
trains of Japan like groping I've heard
that you heard about it yeah I've heard
about it I've never been to Japan can't
wait to go
you heard about it I'm constantly
getting groped out there oh it happens
to you all the [__] time really like
what kind of grubs what kind of growth
because of your hair from behind no like
during um during rush hour right it's
just it's just so it's just not easy to
not touch another human being that I get
that dick is all about my [__] thigh
all this stuff and when I was a kid I
[__] hated like being in the train
because everyone's dick and asses oh on
my [__] face dude just pixelated
it's too much sticking ass dude hey he
actually he actually gave away the
ancient Japanese secret that the
pixelation is an actual thing that it's
not in video it's real but you got to be
born there because Japanese Americans
don't have it yeah so you don't know
sorry dude if you're bored if you're
born in Japan you come out and the baby
got a pixelated private part
it's hard to put the diaper on it
covering right now
because they're like 8-bit Minecraft
[__] you know that's why Nintendo did so
well in Japan yeah it's just real life
that's their thing
yeah but now now you uh you're gonna get
in big trouble for doing these upskirt
things because it's now the whole
country and they did it before those if
you're into upskirt you should just work
at TSA
because then you know even the people
that's what
yeah there's a hack like if it scansia
right you pretty much see like what's
under the clothes and so you could just
be the TSA
oh
like a gynecologist yeah yeah I don't
care anymore so there's um this job
ruined my life I'm trying to put people
in the right places okay
I don't care anymore
you try to optimize society and try to
help you out there's these guys that are
getting that are going pretty viral out
there right now where they catch dudes
um dude it's yeah have you seen them and
then they confront them and [__] and
then that's dangerous yeah that's not a
good idea
I mean I appreciate what they're doing
you know these guys no what is it they
catch uh guys that are in the trains
like doing photo like doing perv [__]
yeah yeah and then just like whoop whoop
their ass or something or no they just
have them on camera and they come from
they just try to embarrass them publicly
and like kind of put them out there just
catch a predator stuff yeah those are
really like there's there's people that
go the extra mile with that stuff too
they'll set people up on like chats and
and be fake people all the way to the
point of confronting them seeing them
face to face yeah yeah but that's that's
dangerous because it almost becomes more
like it's about your content than it is
about the thing it's for sure about the
content yeah because that's good content
if I was looking at that I'd probably
just keep scrolling for like an hour
yeah I'd watch all those things there's
even dudes that they'll they'll camp out
on not camp but like they'll just sit
there on Figueroa and they'll just take
photos and video of every dude that
picks up a prostitute that's that's and
then they'll post it on like a page to
be like just to dissuade people from
like I think this it's like a church
that does it oh because they don't want
people
sitting but they're not doing any
worship at all that's their main gig
yeah they don't do anything they don't
know any lyrics to awesome God yeah they
don't know any of this no Michael W
Smith albums
but yeah that's a dangerous thing
because if it escalates it's like
there's so many things that law wise it
could be their fault too yeah yeah